Let's talk about JSON Web Tokens.
They're often abbreviated as JWT and
they're pronounced like the English word
jot, like,
let me jot a note down about that, Sir.
JWT is a useful standard because
it sends information that can be
verified and
trusted with a digital signature.
Additionally, JWTs are a compact means
of storing data that's easy to decode or
encode in most languages.
JWTs are also ideal for authentication
and information exchange because of
their size and
the fact that they can be signed.
The most common uses for
JWT is authentication, and
we'll explain how that's done soon.
Since JWTs can be signed, you can ensure
that senders are who they say they are,
and that data hasn't been tampered with.
Now, because of the benefits
I outlined earlier, and
because of their
simplicity to set up and
use, we'll be using JWTs in this
course to authenticate our services.